the Joe Rogan experience branding d-boy
Logan Paul in Hawaii
did you really names wandering around
Hawaii do you saying talked over nice
kid right very nice yeah nice I've
talked to him before I talked to him
with you oh that's right we're at the
Omni story is there and he's got a good
fight been there fight was good it was a
good fight they didn't get tired I mean
they [ __ ] went after it for six
rounds dude for guys like that to go you
know I've seen guys who have experienced
an amateur box and they would gas the
[ __ ] out in front of a crowd like that
pretty impressive it's interesting you
know here's a guy also doesn't need to
do that he makes a lot of money a ton of
money makes a ton of money whether you
like it or not that's the reality of it
well someone likes it that's always
making the money but I mean whether
someone listening likes to hear it or
not the truth is he makes a ton of
incorrect you can lie all you know
marries broke took a loss all his money
no no it's got all the my businesses and
he'd still decided to fight which is
interesting it's like okay you know if
you have that competitive driving you
you know if you really do have it in you
I think I think for for him and those
youtubers especially at his level it's
just like what's the next thing that we
can compete like getting everyone behind
and it was that they could have done
ballet dancing whatever it is it would
have sold millions and millions of like
they could but they chose this which I
respect but that chaos a guy who I've
never seen I'm not familiar with him I
know he's British I like British people
so I know he was like they're like a
wonder a room NAT she's like [ __ ] I'm
liking in the face again this was here
dude I'm done well he won for sure so
you know for him that's the best way to
end it yeah he was like I'm out and it
was real controversial you know what the
RAF the penalty yeah again I thought was
ridiculous it was that rough like in
these respected ref was also like you're
in there for this you know this kind of
show like they've take it for what it is
he doesn't have fought for don't take
two points from Logan Paul because of
that two point yeah I didn't got a
warning that's ridiculous I didn't agree
with that
and I think with more fights Logan could
learn how to relax
he gets wild and starts swinging for
sure but Logan stop boxing yeah you have
a jillion dollars keep doing that dude
yeah [ __ ] this exactly exactly
but it was interesting watching like
this kid can punch his athletic man
very athletic ribbon has a work ethic
and in the heat of the battle and he was
trained by Shannon Shannon the Cantor
Briggs let's go champ
let's go check let's go champ was
training them yeah Shannon cannon knows
how to [ __ ] fire yeah he'd know you
did a real camp and it's just like I
respect it but it's a stuff I go dude
I don't maybe well no maybe well yeah
you check that box you're good man
[Applause]